[Music]
four years after the premiere of his
previous directorial effort the Irishman
director Martin scorsi has returned to
the movies with killers of the flower
Moon the film based on the non-fiction
book of the same name by David Gran
tells the real life story of the O Sage
murders of the early 20th century and
based on the critical consensus it is
another instant classic from the
legendary director killers of the flower
Moon opened at the 76th can film
festival on May 20th and it's an
understatement to say that it was
showered with adoration it received a
sustained Standing Ovation by the time
the credits rolled with many in
attendance sharing early praise Flash
Forward 5 months and the scors sessi
feature has arrived in theaters for the
general public to enjoy additionally
Critics on the review aggregator site
Rotten Tomatoes have come along to share
their two cents on the movie and they
are mostly United in praise for the film
which currently boasts a 92% certified
fresh critic score matchable Christy pko
echoed the views of many when she
declared but with killers of the flower
Moon one of the greatest American
filmmakers to ever live has bested even
himself by twisting his previous modus
operandi in crime dramas to demand more
of his audience here's what else the
critics have been saying the Rotten
Tomatoes reviews for killers of the
flower moon have made it clear that
critics found a lot to love about the
film qu Tran Buie of inverse gave the
film credit for its historical honesty
and Martin scorsese's masterful handling
of that history a point of Praise echoed
by numerous other critics this shouldn't
be surprising considering scors sessi
consulted with real members of the oage
nation to deliver an authentic and
introspective account of the tragic
events depicted in the movie in telling
this historical tragedy the New York
times's Manola dargas noted that scors
sessi effortlessly Blended several
genres together describing the movie as
quote a romance a western a domestic
drama a who done it and finally a police
procedural the performance of Lily
Gladstone who plays Molly Burkhart was a
highlight for many critics the Mary Sue
Rachel Lehman wrote Lily Gladstone
performance is so breathtakingly subtle
and Brilliant that it will leave you in
stunned Silence by the end similarly
journalist Shannon Shaw duty of the
Osage news set of Gladstone her presence
her depth her control the nuances she
brings to the role she's brilliant while
Gladstone is no doubt a standout in
these star studded pictur scorsese's
frequent collaborators Leonardo Dicaprio
and Robert dairo also received
considerable amounts of Praise from
critics writing for indiewire critic
David erlick discussed how the film
features quote the best performance of
Leonardo DiCaprio's entire career a
similar sentiment was echoed by Roger
ebert.com critic Brian tallerico who
gushed over Deniro's complicated
performance as the devilish William hail
King describing his character as quote
the kind of sociopath who can sell
murder with a smile for Rotten Tomatoes
critics there's certainly a lot to love
in killers of the flower moon but no
film is perfect and Martin scorsese's
latest isn't escaping criticism the New
Yorkers Anthony Lane wasn't impressed
with the direction the film took and
argued that it stumbled by failing to
capture the perspective of the Osage
Nation Lane suggested that a better and
perhaps more sympathetic version of the
story should be told by an oage creative
Kyle Smith of the Wall Street Journal
didn't care for the Oscar winning
director's latest either describing it
as soulless and predictable for those
who are more critical of the film The
Long runtime and pacing have been cited
as negatives CNN's Brian Lowry wrote
that the film's length did not translate
to an epic scope and concluded scorsi
has served up a movie that also plunges
into a dark history and comes away with
less bang for its bucks though the
length was a sticking point for some
others like Kate Rogers of newshub found
the Colossal 206 minute runtime
perfectly acceptable she wrote scorsi is
a masterful Storyteller and he likes to
take his time so settle in for the 3 and
1 half hour long Rich tapestry of a film
and let it soak right in audiences seem
to be in the same boat as Rotten
Tomatoes critics as ped viewers gave the
film a highly positive a minus Cinema
score Martin scorsese's kers of the
flower moon is now
[Music]
playing